das robert koch institut gewarnt also
man soll sich auch weiterhin an die
abstands und hygiene regeln halten auch
im freien
ja doch am wochenende sei das hier in
berlin etwas anders aus wir sehen gerade
die bilder
deutet man eher den eindruck dass man
feiert als gäbe es überhaupt kein corona
vor allem jugendliche doch warum sind
jugendliche so sorglos darüber möchte
ich jetzt sprechen mit dem
jugendpsychologen doktor christian lüdke
hält schätzen jugendliche einfach die
gefahr etwas anders ein jahr jüngere
menschen haben ein ganz anderes
gefahrenbewusstsein sie fühlen sich
persönlich nicht bedroht sie sehen sich
selber nicht in der risikogruppe und sie
haben einen unheimlichen drang nach
freiheit das heißt also irgendwie ist es
im grunde genommen
zum größten teil egal neben allerdings
natürlich auch in kauf dass sie die
gesundheit anderer menschen gefährden
was ist eine botschaft an die jugend
endzeiten von corona ich würde den
jungen menschen die gerne zu rufen
mensch haltet euch bitte an die regeln
wie alle anderen
es ist hier keine harmlose situation
sondern es geht die teilweise wirklich
um leben und tod stellt das feiern
zurück und wartet bis die situation
wieder sicher ist dankeschön doktor
christian lüdke und das gespräch haben
wir vor der sendung aufgezeichnet